- A California policeman
was intentionally playing
Taylor Swift during a confrontation
with a Black Lives Matter activist
with the idea that if they
were playing copyrighted music,
then the video of this confrontation
could no longer be hosted
on places like YouTube.
- Playing my music so that you can't post
this on YouTube.
- Is a fucking joke.
- This has hilariously backfired
because this video is
absolutely everywhere.
But the question is is it
copyright infringement?
And the answer is probably not.
Though this is a very,
very interesting question
because when we talk about fair use,
we talk about the recognized categories,
things like commentary,
criticism, and education,
and this doesn't really fall into
any of the enumerated
categories that we know of,
but fair use was specifically designed
by Congress to be non-exclusive.
And I think if this case
ever went to the court,
a judge would take one look at it and say,
"This is for a political purpose."
There's no copyright
infringement intended,
and, yes, the cop can
try and get away with it,
but they're not going to,
the video is going to be
promoted pretty much everywhere.
So, if you're a police officer,
I wouldn't recommend doing this,
or we'll see you in court.